It's Canada's secret shame: an epidemic
of missing and murdered Indigenous women
and girls. Indigenous women face a murder
rate six times the national average.
Every time you come out to this river,
do you wonder if you'll recover her body?
We come across remains and you don't
know if they're human or not. Or if they're your sister.
The UN has censured Canada for its ongoing failure to address the crisis.
The march is to send a message to the
men who prey on them that they're being
watched by the community.
We see what's going on. We don't believe that our people deserve it.
These guys do not discriminate.
they go after anybody and everybody.
Now, Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's
government is taking action:
Those touched by this national tragedy have
waited long enough.
But after years of failure on the part of the police and the government, many here questioned if it could
possibly go far enough to bring justice
for the families and keep women safe.
It flashed through my mind that it could be
a body that we were trying to pull up.
We're in Winnipeg, which is one of the
most violent cities in Canada. It also
has the largest urban Indigenous
population in North America. And more
Indigenous women have gone missing or
been murdered here than anywhere else in
the country. The Royal Canadian Mounted
Police, or RCMP, says nearly 1,200
Indigenous women have gone missing or
been murdered across Canada since 1980.
But advocacy groups put the figure far
higher at about 4,000 women. Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's predecessor,
Stephen Harper, largely dismissed the
issue. Then in 2015,
Trudeau announced the creation of a
two-year national inquiry to examine the
epidemic as part of what he called a
"total renewal" of Canada's relationship
with its Indigenous people. But the
inquiry has been plagued by delays,
resignations and allegations of
government interference. Many here feel
it may be destined to fail. Bernadette
Smith's younger sister, Claudette Osborne-Tyo, has been missing since 2008.
Bernadette started "Drag the Red" in
2014 to support other families looking
for answers after the bodies of several
women were found in the Red River. The
group uses homemade dragging bars with
built-in hooks to search the bottom of
the river. They hand over what they find
to police and a team of forensic anthropologists.
Every time we go out, we
offer tobacco to give thanks for
being able to be out here and do
this work, but also to offer prayers to
the families that are missing
someone, that don't have answers
or who had been murdered and nobody's
been brought to justice.
Why this spot in particular?
So this was the Alexander
Dock. There were two young girls that were found here.
In August 2014, the body
of a 15-year-old Indigenous girl named
Tina Fontaine was found in this river,
wrapped in plastic.
Tina's death was a turning point that
opened up a lot of people's eyes to this
epidemic and sent shockwaves across the
country. For many, it highlighted the
failures of the system. In the hours
before her death, she encountered the
police, hospital staff and child welfare workers.
Tell me about your sister, and how she went missing I know she was only 21 at the time, 10 years ago.
She had been sexually abused when she was 12, and
started running away from home. She
ended up with a much older man and was
exploited, and was pushed on to the
streets. Claudette wasn't someone who
didn't stay in contact with someone
daily. Nobody had heard from her in two
days, so my sister Tina went and she
filed a missing persons report. And the
police basically said, "She's out
there somewhere, just give it a few days."
We kept going back to the police
station and saying,
"Something's wrong." They didn't take
us seriously. They didn't investigate her
case for 10 days. So there's a
prime example. That's what they pulled up.
So there's no blood on it, but we pull
up clothing all the time. We've pulled up
lots of underwear, women's underwear. And
people weight bodies down with cement,
right? When they found Tina Fontaine's
body, she was weighted down.
Here we go!
Oh wow. That's a strong tug. Yeah, something definitely got caught on here.
So that's a boot?
More cloth, possibly clothing … and a boot.
It looks like there’s a what?
Remains inside.
They're telling me to check for a foot in here.
It's a branch, or a rock. Could be bone stuff?
It flashed through my mind that it could
be a body that we were trying to pull up,
and it made me feel sick to my stomach,
thinking that's what you guys are here to do.
Our first year, there were seven
bodies recovered from this river.
Every year we've helped, and I don't even
know how many.
Your sister went missing 10 years ago. Every time you come out to this river,
do you wonder if you'll recover her body?
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. That’s … that’s a reality.
You come across remains
and you don't know if they're human or
not. Or if they're your sister. It's an emotional roller coaster, because you just never know.
Three other women in
Bernadette's family have gone missing or
been murdered. Only one case has been solved.
Should it be the police doing this?
Absolutely it should be. Policing is
an issue in this country. We were on the
streets putting up posters, talking to
people, going to different organizations,
going to different places we knew Claudette went to. We were basically
doing the police's job for them. No
family should have to do that.
The Winnipeg Police declined to speak with
us on camera or give us a statement.
“Meet Me at the Belltower” is an anti-violence movement, and we exist to build community.
Michael Champagne is an activist who
organizes weekly anti-violence rallies
in Winnipeg's primarily Indigenous North
End neighborhood. A new mural dedicated
to missing and murdered women has just
been painted in this weekly meeting place.
It’s nice that we have these beautiful images in our community, but it’s frustrating
that they have to be memorial images.
I wanted to know why it was
necessary to hold weekly anti-violence rallies here.
There was a time when, in a
year, we had over 52 vigils, funerals,
hospital room visits, and the same
group people got together but always
centered around the negative things. We
need to host weekly anti-violence
rallies here to send a message. Not only to the
community, but to the people that prey on
our community. And our message is that we are united.
Michael grew up in the child welfare
system here and says that 1 out of 6
children in this neighborhood are
currently in the care of the system.
Seven percent of children across Canada
are Indigenous, but they make up nearly
half of all foster children in the
country. The government cites poverty or
lack of adequate food or housing as
reasons for separating them from their birth families.
What connections do you
see between the child welfare system and
the epidemic of missing and murdered
Indigenous women?
In the child welfare system, often what ends up happening is a devaluing of Indigenous life, especially
for Indigenous women and girls. As they
age out of care, they turn eighteen unequipped
with life skills, severed from their
biological families or their home
communities. They're at risk of
homelessness, harmful substance use,
sexual exploitation. Part of the reason
why we have such difficulties in child
welfare today is that many of those
children right now are actually children,
like me, of Indian residential school survivors.
From the 1840s to the mid-1990s, some 150,000 Indigenous children were removed from their
families and sent to church- and
government-run Indian residential
schools. Their aim was to "kill the Indian
in the child" by assimilating them into
dominant Canadian culture. Many children
suffered emotional, physical and sexual
abuse while attending these schools. As
we know now, Indian residential schools
were a failed experiment that did a lot
more harm than it did good.
And unfortunately, that that history of
family separation over so many
generations continues to this day with
child welfare.
It's 12:30 a.m. here in the North End
neighborhood in Winnipeg, and we've
joined this Midnight Medicine Walk
organized by the community to reach out
to women here that are being sexually
exploited, to offer them prayers and
medicine and let them know that they're
being watched after. And also, the march is
to send a message to the men who prey on
them that they're being watched by the
community. Lauren Chopeck is the
founder of the walk. She was once a
missing Indigenous woman herself.
Lauren ran away from home as a teenager
and was trafficked on these streets,
where she narrowly escaped a serial killer.
How did the idea of the Midnight
Medicine Walk come about?
Through my own experiences of
being exploited. I wanted to do something
to acknowledge those people as really
actually really are, and acknowledge
their spirits and honor their spirits, instead of
just walking past them every day,
or driving past them every day, thinking of them as homeless people or as prostitutes.
Because that’s not who they are.
Tell me about some of the interactions you
have with these women that you're reaching out to on the streets, and what really sticks with you.
They tear up, these women, because they're finally
being recognized. And they might not feel
like they deserve
this kind of standing ovation that we
give them, when we stop and sing for them
or we offer them a smudge. They feel like they don’t deserve it.
But they do, and they're finally being paid attention to.
Is this process really healing for you?
It is. It is really healing for me. Out of
all those negative experiences I had as
a young girl being sexually exploited,
now people recognize me and they respect
me for those things, I guess, but in a different way, because now I turned it into something beautiful.
As we turned the corner onto the main
boulevard, we were told that no one takes
this road at night unless they're looking for sex.
What message are you guys sending to the men out there who prey on these vulnerable women?
That we see what's going on and that we don't
believe that our people deserve it. I
want them to see the community coming together.
Because the police's response has been
insufficient, Indigenous activists have
been stepping up in various ways to ensure the safety of their community members and streets.
OK, so two groups of seven. We've got 14, right?
James Favel is the executive director of the
Bear Clan Patrol, a community safety
patrol that operates in some of Winnipeg's toughest neighborhoods five to six nights a week.
When we talk about
the epidemic of missing and murdered
Indigenous women and girls here in this
country, do you see your work as trying
to put an end to that, in a small way?
That's exactly why we started. In the wake of what
happened with Tina Fontaine, I just wasn't
prepared to sit around and watch anymore.
I had to do something so I could at
least sleep at night and my conscience be
clear. We started out with 12
volunteers in 2014, and now we have 1,200.
How does that make you feel?
It’s pretty f*cking good.
Tell me a bit more about the sexual exploitation you see on these streets.
Well, I mean, it's – yeah, the prostitution here, it was
pervasive for a very long time, and there
was nobody doing anything about it. It
was like it was permitted in this area.
and for us here in this
community, that's not suitable,
right? We have the exploited
women, standing up against
buddy's fence, and the kids are
playing in the yard and we've got Johns
coming. These guys do not
discriminate, they go after anybody and
everybody, they don't care if you're 10
years old or if you're 40 years old.
Why hasn't the state or the city done more
to crack down on these Johns?
... the political will is not there.
Canada’s National Inquiry into Missing and
Murdered Indigenous Women and Girls is
expected to conclude in April of 2019.
The inquiry is examining the systematic
causes of violence against Indigenous
women and girls, and making
recommendations for how to keep them
safe – at a cost of $53.8 million. During our time in
Winnipeg, we heard from those who feel
the inquiry may not be up to the task.
Our family didn't participate in that
inquiry. We called for a national action
plan. Women are still going
missing. They're still being murdered, and
there's no real resources or prevention put in place to stop that from happening.
I feel like this inquiry needs to be led
by experiential family members that
actually know what it's like to lose a
loved one, so that we have an appropriate
amount of urgency behind the work that we're doing.
Tasha Spillett is an academic and educator who's been following the inquiry.
I don't see that there will be
any outcome in it, unless there's real
legal teeth from that from that inquiry.
We’re going to have another inquiry in 50 years, another one in 100 years, another one in 150
years if we don't understand that at the
bottom of this is a really harmful power
dynamic in which Indigenous women and
girls are situated at the bottom.
We wanted to take these concerns to Prime Minister Justin Trudeau,
but his office declined our request for
an interview. Instead, they directed us to
Carolyn Bennett, the Minister of Crown–Indigenous Relations. For months, we
reached out to her office for an
interview, and eventually received a
statement that stresses the government's
commitment to, in their words, "end this national
tragedy," and lists the initiatives it's taking to support affected communities and prevent future violence.
In the meantime, as Canada's
government struggles to repair its
relationship with its Indigenous
population, the communities here are
continuing to search for their missing
women – while trying to stop the next one
from being murdered.
We've made it part of Claudette's legacy to help other families, to do whatever we can to create awareness,
to honor her.
Hey everyone, it's Dena. So how much did you know about the epidemic of missing and murdered
Indigenous women and girls? Let me know
in the comments and be sure to check out
our next Direct From episode where I
travel to British Columbia to report on
the fight against the Trans Mountain
Pipeline. Make sure to like and share
this video and subscribe to AJ+.